Hello class of 2026,
my name is Julie, I'm
one of the scholars and
today I'll be giving
the lecture for
bacterial CNS infections.
And I'd like to
thank Dr. Sleeman
for giving me this
opportunity and
helping me so much
along the way.
Here are the
learning objectives.
So by the end of
this lecture, you
should be able to
describe the different
types of bacterial
CNS infections
and their etiology,
compare and
contrast bacterial
and viral meningitis,
compare the properties
of most common
bacterial
etiological agents of
meningitis, and identify
the importance of
diagnostic CSF
analysis and therapies,
and illustrate the
role the patient age
plays in the
determination of bacterial
etiology of meningitis.
I also made a little
outline. All of
this is included in
some way in the learning
objectives, but it
may make things a
little clearer or help
with following along
with the lecture.
So let's get started.
There's a few terms
to understand. When
we say meningitis,
that's referring
to inflammation of
the meninges, so the
dura, pia, arachnoid
matter. Remember
that they encase the
CNS, and you can
look at the image to
the right to kind
of refresh yourself.
And meningitis can
be classified in a
few ways. It can be
acute, so symptoms
come on suddenly or
over a few days. Or it
can be chronic,
so symptoms can be
present for weeks or
months, usually less
severe than in an
acute presentation. And
we'll talk more
about these later on.
Meningitis can also
be bacterial, viral,
fungal, or aseptic.
This is determined based
on the etiology or
the cause of disease.
Cerebral spinal fluid
gets cultured. If
bacteria grows, it's
bacterial. If ****** grows,
it's fungal. A virus
can cause meningitis
and it's viral. But
aseptic doesn't mean it's
not caused by one of
these. It just means
that nothing can be
cultured from the CSF.
When we say
encephalitis, that is
referring to
inflammation of the brain
parenchyma or tissue,
and myelitis refers
to inflammation of
the spinal cord.
We'll also go over brain
abscesses in
this lecture.
And just to get you
thinking, why are we
even talking about
all of this? Why can
inflammation be so
serious for the CNS?
It can happen all
over the body, right?
Well, this is in part
due to the restrictive
barriers of the
skull and vertebral
column. Although they
protect the brain and
spinal cord, when
there is inflammation,
edema, any kind of
displacing of the inner
contents, there is
not much room for
anything to go. This
increases intracranial
pressure, pushes
structures against each
other, resulting in the
symptoms of meningitis
and encephalitis
that we'll go over.
Since inflammation
of the CNS can be so
detrimental, mental, our
bodies don't allow it
to happen unless
absolutely necessary. So
this explains why our
CNS has a limited immune
response. And with
that limited immune
response, it gives
pathogens a nice, cozy,
protected place to hide
in the body. In order to
get to the CNS, there
are a few routes
pathogens can take.
There's the hematogenous
route, including infection
from our respiratory
epithelium, like when
you have meningococcal
disease, infection
from a bite, or
transplacental transmission.
All of these can allow
pathogens to enter the
blood and reach the
central nervous system
through the choroid
plexus, which we
remember makes cerebral
spinal fluid. Or these
pathogens can directly
infect CNS endothelial
cells from the blood.
Entry can also
occur through direct
inoculation during
trauma or surgery. And
while getting into
the CNS, these
pathogens have to evade
the immune system.
Being able to evade
the immune system
and infect the host
is dependent on
multiple factors,
one of which are
virulence factors,
things like capsules,
specifically the
sialic acid in
capsules help
bacteria adhere to the
meninges and hide
from immune cells.
There's also IgA
protease, hemolysis,
being able to evade
the complement system.
Another factor is the
actual host. Someone
who is immunocompromised,
the elderly,
children under a year,
they have delicate
immune systems making
them more susceptible.
Then you also have
to take into account
bacterial load.
The more bacteria
that infects someone,
the more likely
the immune system
can't fight it off.
Additionally, the
CNS immune system has
protection through the
blood-brain barrier,
microglia, and Virchow
-Robbins spaces.
Virchow-Robbins
spaces are areas of
lymphatics within the
CNS where immune cells
can exist. And even
though the CNS has
these, it's not a
lot once bacteria has
entered. It's like
there's a big gate
protecting our central
nervous system, but
there's not much
defense on the inside.
The actual damage to
the central nervous
system can occur directly
from the bacteria,
replicating and
destroying cells, but
a lot of the damage
also comes from the
inflammatory response.
When infection gets
to the CNS, chemokines
and cytokines from
affected tissues are
released, increasing
capillary permeability,
more phagocytes
and immune cells come
to the rescue, and
because of this
permeability, more immune
cells than usual are
entering the CNS.
Enzymes are then
released, edema occurs,
and this increases
pressure in the central
nervous system,
which can displace
structures leading
to herniation or even
result in decreased
CSF and venous flow.
All of that damage
is seen on clinical
presentation with the
typical symptoms of
meningitis. Headaches,
altered mental status,
nuchal rigidity,
petechiae on
the extremities
and trunk. These
symptoms can be
described as
focal or global.
Focal meaning
only affecting the
nervous system or
specific neural deficits
and global
referring to more
systemic symptoms
like the petechiae or
fever or GI symptoms,
for example.
With some of that
background info, we
can point out the
differences between
acute bacterial and
viral meningitis.
In bacterial, you'll
see either focal
or global symptoms,
but with viral,
it's almost always
focal symptoms.
Cerebrospinal fluid
analysis will also look
different between the
two, with bacterial
meningitis showing an
increase in opening
pressure, an increase
in polymorphonuclear
cells, especially the
neutrophils, an increase
in protein, and a
decrease in glucose.
But viral meningitis
could show normal
to increased opening
pressure, more
lymphocytes, not
neutrophils, normal
protein, and normal
to increased glucose.
There's a high
morbidity and mortality
in bacterial meningitis
that requires
immediate antibiotic
therapy and low
morbidity or
mortality in viral
meningitis that will
need supportive care.
And here's a figure
showing some more
detailed measurements
for a typical CSF
analysis. Take a
look at this, orient
yourselves, because the
results from hospital
labs will actually
be presented to you
more like this than
in the previous table.
Okay, to break up
the video a little
bit, we have our
first review question.
So take a minute
and pause the video
and try to go over
it on your own.
And if you pause the
video, welcome back.
So the first one,
in a suspected case
of meningitis, CSF
containing high protein
and low glucose
may indicate which
should be bacterial
meningitis, which
requires immediate
antibiotic treatment.
And the second one,
in a suspected case of
meningitis, CSF containing
high lymphocytes
and normal glucose
may indicate viral
meningitis, which requires
supportive treatment.
Now we'll move on
to acute bacterial
meningitis. Like we said
before, acute, meaning
the onset is sudden,
with rapid progression
of symptoms over a
few days. This can
occur from an isolated
infection, but it's
more common in
septicemia, or when a pre
-existing infection
spreads throughout the
body and into the
central nervous system.
We also mentioned
some of these symptoms
before, but you
should note that in
perillolent infections,
where the bacteria
produce a lot of pus,
this will result in
increased pressure and
more serious symptoms
like nausea, vomiting,
CNS depression.
With acute bacterial
meningitis, you'll
also learn that the cause
is very age dependent,
and this is fatal
without treatment.
Here you can see
some common bacterial
causes of acute meningitis
depending on the
age of the patient.
So in newborns, group
B strep, E. coli,
and listeria are the
most common etiologies
in children and
adults. Here it says
children, but it goes
up to 60 years. So
children and adults,
strep pneumo, neisseria,
meningitis, and
H flu are very common.
And in the elderly,
strep pneumo, listeria,
and the others
can be common. But
just because there are
these common groups
that help us in
looking at the patient,
this does not mean
that a newborn can't
get strep pneumo or
that an adult can't
get meningitis from
listeria, but it is
less likely. It's also
important to note that
strep pneumo is most
common among most
of these age groups.
And just to throw
in that vaccination
does make a
difference. There are
vaccines for strep
pneumo, H flu,
Neisseria, and these
decrease overall
cases of meningitis
in those age groups.
And at any age,
cranial or dental
surgeries can make
someone susceptible to
staph aureus or staph
epidermidis, but
with staph aureus
infection will likely
lead to an abscess
and not meningitis.
And in the
immunocompromised, they'll
be at risk of most
of these pathogens,
but also for
reactivation of latent
TB, leading to chronic
meningitis, which
we'll get into a
little bit later.
Like we said before,
antibiotics are
necessary for treatment,
but cerebrospinal
fluid and blood
cultures should be
taken first if possible.
Never delay
antibiotics if this is
not possible, but
once antibiotics are
given, the cultures
won't grow anything.
You always
start with broad
-spectrum bactericidal
antibiotics,
so your ceftriaxone,
cefetaxime.
Providers are
starting to include
vancomycin more often
due to increasing
resistance to
these beta-lactams.
And if listeria
is suspected,
you'll add ampicillin
to your regimen.
There's also been
data to suggest that
dexamethasone reduces
morbidity and mortality in
some cases, especially
those due to H-flu.
This isn't quite as
clear in cases of
other etiologies,
but the basis behind
this is a reduction
in inflammation
from the dexamethasone
is beneficial.
Anyone that has been
in direct contact
with the patient
should also get
prophylaxis. And just
to remind yourselves,
know the antibiotics
that would
not be helpful since
they do not cross
the blood-brain
barrier as easily.
And these are some of
the bacteria that can
be responsible for acute
bacterial meningitis
like we saw in some
of the tables earlier,
so we'll go over just
a few of them now.
These slides are a little
meaty but hopefully
most of it is
familiar and the more
you see some of these
important points about
microbes especially
in the clinical
context the more prepared
you'll be for boards.
So first up we have
strep pneumo a gram
positive lancet shaped
diplococci that you
can see in the gram
stain to the right.
It can be part of
the normal flora of
the nose and throat
with aerosol and
droplet transmission.
It produces pus,
so increasing that
edema and pressure
of the CNS, leading
to high mortality
and detrimental
neurological deficits.
Beta-lactam resistance
is common, so
vancomycin is needed.
It also produces IgA
protease and hemolycin,
because it is
alpha-hemolytic, and
it has a capsule. With
multiple serotypes of
the capsule antigens,
there are actually
a few vaccines
that can cover multiple
of these strains.
You don't have to
memorize the schedule
for vaccination now,
but know that some
are given to infants
and children and
others are given to
the elderly or those at
risk, so the
immunocompromised, smokers,
people with diabetes
or hypertension.
These are our
pneumococcal vaccines.
And because of
this capsule,
asplenic patients
and those with
immune disorders
are at risk.
Just to remind ourselves
also that strep
pneumo doesn't only
cause meningitis,
but it also commonly
causes otitis media,
pneumonia, and sinusitis.
Next up is Neisseria
meningitidis,
or meningococcal disease.
This is a gram
-positive diplococci.
You can see it
on the gram stain
to the right.
Those arrows are
pointing to it.
It's very small.
it is also part of our
normal flora and has
aerosol droplet
transmission it grows on
blood agar has a capsule
produces ig protease
beta lactamase and
during multiplication it
can form blebs that
help it spread between
cells we can produce
antibodies to its
capsular antigens but a
large part of our defense
against it is through
the complement system
and you'll learn
more over time that
people with complement
deficiencies or diseases
are more at risk for
Neisseria infection.
And this might not
present as severely
as some other causes
of meningitis,
but it is becoming
harder to treat.
Penicillin used to
be used, and now we
use third-gen
cephalosporins, but like
I said, it produces
beta-lactamase and
is actually on a list
of the WHO for drug
-resistant bacteria
to watch out for.
And just be aware
that there are
vaccines, one that
covers the ACWNY
strains and one for
meningococcal B.
Listeria monocytogenes.
This is a gram
-positive intracellular
rod. You can see it's
gram-stained to the
right. It's commonly a
cause of meningitis in
newborns, the elderly,
the immunocompromised,
with
high mortality
in those groups.
Transmission occurs
from mother to fetus
or through the *****
oral route. It can
actually grow at pretty
chilled temperatures
and is tolerant to
some preservatives like
salts and nitrites.
This is one reason why
pregnant women are told
to avoid deli meats,
because if they were
to ingest listeria,
they might not experience
illness from it,
but they could pass
it on to their baby.
And it also produces
listerolysin, which
makes pores in
phagosomes, allowing
listeria to enter the
cytoplasm when engulfed,
escaping degradation
by phagocytes.
It can take over cellular
actin polymerization,
allowing it to
move within cells
and spread to other
cells. And remember
that listeria is
treated with ampicillin.
Group B strep, or
strep A galactiae,
is a gram-positive
coccyon chain,
which you can see
in the gram stain.
It has a capsule,
is resistant to
bacitracin, and performs
beta-hemolysis, so
complete destruction
of red blood cells.
It can be part of our
normal flora in the
upper respiratory tract
and the genitourinary
tract, which is why
it can be contracted
by a baby from its
mother during pregnancy
or birth, and there is
a higher risk of this
with complications of
pregnancy or delivery,
like ********* rupture
of the membranes,
prolonged labor,
pre-term birth, but
also if the mother
is actively sick
from a systemic group
B strep infection,
or if the mother
can't produce antibodies
against strep B.
To prevent transmission
during birth, pregnant
people will be swabbed
for the presence
of group B strep in
their vaginal and ****
canals, and if present,
penicillin G is
administered every four
hours during labor.
So here's another
review question. You can
pause the video and go
over it for a minute.
Okay, so what bacteria
is the most likely
etiology of this
patient's meningitis?
I would say Neisseria
meningitidis. And if
we were to go back and
look at the question
stem to pick out points
of it that kind of
hint us to this diagnosis,
I would say we would
be looking at the fact
that it's a 20-year
-old patient who has
no significant past
medical history. So
they're likely healthy, not
immunocompromised, not
elderly, not a baby.
So that's our first
clue to pick out
which bacteria is likely
to cause. He's also
a college student.
And if you know from
any outbreaks that
normally happen for
meningitis or
meningococcal disease.
College campuses is
a very prominent one.
This patient's
vaccination status is
also unknown, so
that could also hint
to why he would
have gotten this
form of meningitis if
he's not vaccinated
with the meningococcal
vaccines.
And lastly, the gram
-negative diplococci
growing on his
cultures are a
giveaway for Neisseria
meningitidis.
So we just covered acute
bacterial meningitis
and now we'll go over
chronic bacterial
meningitis. Chronic
meaning symptoms
are present for weeks
to months and someone
usually only seeks
out care because of
an acute worsening of
these symptoms. It's
commonly caused by
fungi like Cryptococcus
neophormans, which
you'll learn more
about in another lecture,
but it can also be
caused by latent
tuberculosis infection.
Usually in the
immunocompromised, latent
TB can reactivate
or spread to the CNS
where it forms
granulomas and causes
inflammation leading
to meningitis and its
symptoms. To diagnose
this, you'll often check
in acid fasting,
which uses rhodamine
oramine, a compound
that detects mycolic
or check for
tubulocosteric acid in
the CSF. But these
methods cannot
rule out TB as a
cause if they show up
negative. The
gold standard to
diagnose it is with
CSF culture for TB,
which can take up
to eight weeks.
Since TB has developed
multi-drug resistance
in the past few
decades, treatment
requires a multi-drug
cocktail of rifampin,
isoniazid, purizanamide,
and ethambutol,
which are just here
for your information.
You'll have more
lectures on TB in the
future, but to point
out some of the damaging
effects of TB
meningitis, the image
on the right shows
multiple kinds of
tuberculomas that can
form in the brain, clearly
impeding on and
displacing structures.
Here we can talk
about brain abscesses.
These are different
from meningitis in that
they are focal
infections of the brain
tissue. They're also
encapsulated and well
separated from surrounding
structures, but
their presence can cause
deficits of whichever
lobe they are present
in. For example,
a frontal lobe abscess
can cause working
memory difficulty
and problems with
decisions. Temporal
lobe abscesses
could cause visual
or auditory deficits.
The microbes that cause
abscesses can reach
the brain either by
direct contact in
surgery or trauma,
through the blood after
dental surgery or pre
-existing infection, or
through the sinus
connections of the skull.
These abscesses can
be caused by bacteria,
fungi, parasites. Since
we focused on bacteria
for this lecture,
some common ones
include Staph aureus,
group A or D strep, and
commonly a mix of a
bunch of bacteria at
once. In chronic cases,
TB is a common cause.
Diagnosing an abscess
can be tricky. Imaging
like CT or MRI can be
done, and aspirating
the abscess can
also be done, but
this can be invasive.
So it is important to
rule out ****** or
tumor in these cases.
Because abscesses wall
themselves off well
and cause little
inflammation, antibiotics
aren't always effective.
They can't *********
through the abscess and
they can't even pass
by the blood-brain
barrier if there is no
inflammatory response,
making the capillaries
more permeable. And
that's why there is
such a high mortality
even with treatment. But
vancomycin, ceftriaxone,
and cefetaxime are
used, and metronidazole
for fungal cases.
And our last
review question,
so pause and
take a good go.
Okay, so the ways to
diagnose chronic TB
meningitis are on a
previous slide, but
just to mention them
again, the gold standard
is cerebrospinal
fluid culture for TB.
You can also check
for the presence of
tuberculosteric acid
in the CSF, can perform
an acid fast stain on
the CSF and PCR, but
if negative, those
will not rule out TB.
You really should check
for the full CSF culture.
And here is a quick
summary slide covering
everything we
went over and the
references in case
you want to read more.
I also want to thank you
so much for listening
I hope it was helpful
and if you have any
questions or concerns
don't hesitate to
email me or Dr. Schleeman
we might not get back
to you immediately but
we definitely won't
leave you hanging and if
you're still listening
at this point I also
want to point out
a few things just so
you don't forget how
cool it is to be in the
positions that you're
in I know med school
can be hard and there's
so much going on and
so many things to keep
track of that you
feel weighed down and
unmotivated but if you're
able to just take a
quick moment to be really
proud of yourselves
and let yourself
enjoy this time. The
experience of being a
medical student and being
an osteopathic medical
student is so unique.
You're learning an insane
amount of information
and things that some
people will never
hear about in their
lifetime and that is
just so cool and you're
so lucky. There is so
much knowledge in the
world and we aren't
even exposed to a fraction
of it, but what we
are being exposed to
is amazing. The human
body is amazing,
medicine is amazing, the
tools we have to treat
are amazing, and you
haven't been on rotations
yet, but if you've
ever had clinical
experience, working with
patients and real people
with real stories is
amazing. And we get to
do this for the rest
of our lives. I know
there are so many times
where stress and
inequalities in the world
can really harm at
least my outlook on this
path, but taking a
moment to remember all of
this and remember the
bigger picture. It's
so important to keep you
motivated. I apologize
if I sound sappy or
if you really don't
want to hear all of
this, but just be really,
really proud of
yourselves and all that
you've done and in
making the decision to go
into medicine. And
know that I'm extremely
proud of you for choosing
this path too. So
thanks for coming to my
TED Talk. Stay motivated
and please fill out
the feedback form.
It's super helpful
for yourselves, future
students, and especially
me as I'm just learning
how to do this kind
of thing. Thank you.